friends and relatives of andrew brown jr
are
furious with the district attorney who
declared the deputies who killed brown
were justified
and will not face charges the d.a
revealed police body cam video of the
shooting for the first time
sheriff's deputies fired into brown's
car while trying to
serve an arrest warrant last month his
family calls the death
an execution jeff pigues is outside the
sheriff's office in elizabeth city north
carolina jeff good morning
good morning there is likely hours of
body camera footage from this shooting
and whether we eventually see that is
going to be up to a judge
but yesterday the d.a here released what
he believes is the critical
44 seconds and he released video from
four different body cams we want to warn
you that what you're about to see
is disturbing body camera video shows
heavily armed deputies sitting in the
back of a police pickup truck
they pull up on andrew brown jr to serve
a drug related warrant
brown is behind the wheel of the blue
sedan
as deputies close in on him
brown then backs the car up and turns to
the left away from officers
deputies open fire and the car speeds
away before
crashing into a tree district attorney
andrew wumble says brown's attempt to
flee
made his vehicle a deadly weapon mr
brown's death while tragic
was justified because mr brown's actions
caused three deputies with the pasco
tank county sheriff's office
to reasonably believe it was necessary
to use deadly force
womble says brown's car made contact
with one of the deputies
in total they fired 14 shots hitting
brown in the right arm in the back of
the head
brown was unarmed you're saying he was
threatening them but then he's backing
away and it's the officer going for the
car
that is a threat and i don't care what
direction you're going
forward backward sideways i don't care
if you're stationary
and neither do our courts and our case
law the district attorney's
press conference was an attempt to
whitewash
the unjustified killing of andrew brown
jr
ben crump one of the brown family
attorneys says brown was trying to drive
away from deputies
and pose no threat the most cowardly
thing you could ever do
is shoot a person from behind where
they're not
posing any threat or harm of violence to
you
in that press conference you could see
that the d.a was
adamant about what he views are the
facts of this case that
brown by reacting to the officers and
the way that he did
turn that vehicle into a deadly weapon
and there have been court cases in the
past
uh similar to this where you have
encounters between
someone and police where a vehicle has
been
viewed as a deadly weapon but it is also
worth mentioning that in that
shooting just three of the seven cops
fired
all 14 shots which raises the question
of
did the other four officers perceive
a different threat it's an excellent
point jeff
thank you very much for your reporting
we appreciate it i thought jeff's
question during that press conference
was
the most critical one he said you say
you're saying that they're threatening
you
yeah the police officers but he's
backing away backing away and then he's
trying to get away and i think when we
originally heard from the police
before we got to see the tape you were
led to believe that he deliberately
tried to hit a police officer that
clearly was not the case
he was trying to get away and it looked
like he might have skimmed the police
officer
but i don't understand the use of all
the fire power as a guy as
andrew brown is is clearly trying to get
away
well and essentially use of lethal force
in a situation
like this can't you shoot out the tires
i mean i don't under the understand the
tactics that's my
also the video of them the way they were
approaching to in that truck with it
seemed i saw assault rifles like they
were really trying
to be on a hunt just to serve a warrant
now
we all have heard he had a criminal
record i understand that i get that
but there's just something the optics of
it do not look good i'll say that the
d.a believes the law is on his side yeah
we'll see clearly and right now it is
that's right that's right